as you enter my house not my wife and I
wanted to have some kind of artwork that
was personal to the house and also
related to the work that we do and so
the circuit all you see two things one
of them is the dragon curve I'm explain
to you more about in a minute and
another one is this work here which is a
group by Piet Hein road to wisdom well
it's plain and simple to express her and
her and her again but less and less and
less it's one of my favorite it sort of
the story of my life is making mistakes
and trying to have learned from that
they designed it in the shape of a super
ellipse which is Pete Hines a great
great discovery of a of a ellipse that
that is is more full and has been used
in in many architectural products so
what's the idea of the dragon curve this
is something is ended by a couple of
physicists late 60s and start a good
piece of paper and you fold it fold it
again and you fold it again and you do
this end times where n is nine in the
case of the dragon curve B to our left
with care n is for something but what
when you look at it you see that some of
the folds ago and I'm out and fold
summer Valley folds if you imagine
walking here you're turning left here
you turning left here but then you're
turning right and another right turn I
left her and so on so so there's a
pattern of left's and rights the amazing
thing is that if you continue this like
nine times and then you open all these
folds up to ninety degree then you get a
path starts to fill the space and makes
it quite a nice practical pattern so
start here with at this tile for example
if you if you zoom in on it you can see
that my wife and I had signed our names
here but we
talk about that story later but it
starts out and makes a left turn and a
left and a right turn and a left turn
left and so on so this is exactly that
the pattern that you get from folding
since I four nine times there's five
hundred and twelve steps to this well
511 probably to this pattern so it ends
it ends over here and it keeps going but
in the middle it gets very intricate and
I think great thing is though from a
standpoint of geek art you know is that
you only need three kinds of tiles tile
that's completely blank or a tile that
has one loop in it like this one or a
tile that has two loops in it like this
one and of course I could take the tile
with two loops and I could tip it this
way then it wouldn't be joining from
here to here but it would be yet that
would make this into an isolated circle
all right yeah I had to count how many
blacks my blanks I needed how many were
single loops and so on and out and so we
made a mock-up in in brown paper and
cardboard and had it in the apartment
where we were living while our house was
being designed and we said hey this is a
cool designer kind of nice to have this
in our house when when house was finally
built so then we we both loved the tiles
that are made by Heath ceramics in
Sausalito California and we had a
mock-up of the design so we went up to
see the ceramics and talked to the
people there and we have to wonder if
they could make custom tiles for us
number blank certain number of single
and the answer was well we could do it
except that we all we only make tiles
that are three and a half inches square
and what my design called for two inches
square if this if the mathematics could
not be changed even if I went down to
eight instead of nine it wouldn't have
been if it wouldn't been as interesting
a pattern but also it would be huge and
wouldn't look right at scale this
this kind of pattern is very appealing
at this size but not at a bigger size so
we were down we look very disheartened
up evidently because the person we were
talking to saw that we were very
disappointed that we had you know driven
up here and had this nice idea but they
said what weight that we took one week
in June we're going on vacation we
closed our factory and you who but but
we have somebody here is a security
person you could come in and use our
equipment we let you use our clay and
extrude tiles and if you cut them to the
size to two inches by two inches then I
will also let you put on our glazes and
we'll fire the tiles for you afterwards
and so that's that's what we did we we
went up there and spent a day making all
these tiles in a few spares and put our
initials in this one worked the starting
point then they fired it and there are
some of the accidents in the fire and
you can see sometimes it cracked a
little bit during the during the firing
so we had we had nine of these actually
so I could so I put those in so that
after but like after after eight steps
it's here and then after 16 years here
32 I'm here so years went by and and I
finally put a chapter in my book on fun
and games that talks about this and I
read all the papers I had written about
the dragon curve and come to a shocking
discovery that is that this is wrong you
get this by making nine folds but the
ninth fold I made in the wrong direction
instead of going this way I went that
way
and so actually this is the last half of
this
Bend and there's something
mathematically I've been living with
this for thirty years and didn't realize
that I had a mathematical error in the
design how do you feel well I feel the
moral is earn or or again but less and
less and less numberphile is made
possible by support from the
mathematical sciences Research Institute
we'll have more from Don Knuth coming
soon so stay tuned to numberphile and
our sister channel computerphile where
those videos will be appearing and if
you'd like to watch even more about the
dragon curve we've done some previous
videos on that which go into more detail
links are on the screen and in the video
description
you